So I think one of the great powers of AI was just getting into that first gear, right? Right. How do you just get started on this problem? Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 253 recorded on August 21st, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat with Sean Parent, about cursor and AI. But you mentioned, you know, my comment and my push, and that was the Adobe Source Libraries, which these are where the Adam Library is,
我认为人工智能的一大威力在于刚刚挂上那一档，对吧？没错。你该如何着手解决这个问题？欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，这是 2025 年 8 月 21 日录制的第 253 期节目。我是 Connor，今天我和联合主持人 Bryce 将与 Sean Parent 聊聊 Cursor 和人工智能。但你提到了我的评论和推动，那就是 Adobe 源代码库，Adam 库就在那里，
and, you know, I've maintained it for 20-something years as kind of a side project since the previous Software Technology Lab. And during the period where I left Adobe, went to Google. There was like an update to the doxygen tool and it broke the generation of oxygen and like badly broke the generation of the documentation. So I've left the old site online but for 20 years I haven't been able to build the documentation and I took a stab at one point and Foster got Foster Bert and somebody I work with he got a couple of the files building at one point, but it was like the more time that went by, the more impossible and
你知道，作为前软件技术实验室的一个副项目，我已经维护它二十多年了。在我离开 Adobe 去 Google 的那段时间里，Doxygen 工具进行了一次更新，导致它破坏了文档生成，严重破坏了文档的生成。所以我保留了旧网站在线，但 20 年来我一直无法构建文档。我曾尝试过一次，Foster，也就是 Foster Bert，我的一位同事，他曾设法构建了几个文件，但随着时间的推移，这似乎变得越来越不可能，
intractable it seemed. And part of it was when we originally wrote the documentation, you know, I didn't have a folding editor. So I hated having big blocks of description in my source files. So I wrote all the documentation as external in external.dox files. And for oxygen to match those up, it means the signatures have to match. But the signatures don't match textually exactly. They used to match
越来越棘手。部分原因是我们在最初编写文档时，没有折叠编辑器。所以我讨厌在源文件中出现大段的描述。因此，我把所有的文档都写成了外部的 .dox 文件。为了让 Doxygen 将它们匹配起来，这意味着签名必须匹配。但签名在文本上并不完全匹配。它们过去是通过
through Doxygen's old AST parser, and now they have to match through the Clang AST parser because Doxygen has moved to clang. Okay? So if you think about, you know, you've got several thousand functions
Doxygen 的旧 AST 解析器匹配的，而现在它们必须通过 Clang AST 解析器来匹配，因为 Doxygen 已经转向了 Clang。明白吗？所以如果你考虑到，你知道，你有几千个函数
in there, and And those signatures don't match, and you can't copy and paste to fix them. And even if you could copy and paste, you have to be able to figure out which one matches with which one. And they're written in a different form. And now, 20 years later, the API is probably changed.
在里面，而那些签名不匹配，你无法通过复制粘贴来修复它们。即使你能复制粘贴，你也必须能够弄清楚哪一个与哪一个匹配。而且它们是以不同的形式编写的。现在 20 年过去了，API 可能已经改变了。
So you have this huge problem of trying to figure out, like, OK, which documentation goes with which function. And because of overloading, you can't even just say, oh, I'm just going to search for the name of the function. It's like, oh, great, I got five of them. So which one of the five documentations goes with which one of the five overloads?
所以你面临一个巨大的问题，就是试图弄清楚，好吧，哪个文档对应哪个函数。而且由于重载的存在，你甚至不能只说，哦，我只要搜索函数名就行了。结果是，太棒了，我搜到了五个。那么这五个文档中哪一个对应哪一个重载呢？
Right, right, right. And now there's probably six overloaded, so which one am I missing? Right. And so every time I took a stab at it, I was just like, this is just too much work. It's not worth it. I'm not doing it. I'm out.
对，对，对。而且现在可能有六个重载，所以我漏掉了哪一个？对。所以每次我尝试的时候，我都觉得，这工作量太大了。不值得。我不干了。我退出。
So I think one of the great powers of AI was just getting into that first gear, right? How do you just get started on this problem? So I wrote this huge prompt and, you know, took me a couple of tries where I'm like, no, you're going way off in the weeds and like reset it, set it. But I ended up with this, you know, a big huge prompt where it was like, okay, here's the deal. This is what I'm trying to do. You know, this is what has happened. Here's the history of it.
所以我认为人工智能的一大威力在于刚刚挂上那一档，对吧？你该如何着手解决这个问题？所以我写了这个巨大的提示词，你知道，花了几次尝试，我心想，不，你跑题跑得太远了，然后重置它，设置它。但我最终得到了这个，你知道，一个巨大的提示词，内容是，好吧，情况是这样的。这就是我想要做的。你知道，这就是发生的事情。这是它的历史。
here's the problem, here's the challenge, formulate a plan for how we're going to approach this incrementally. Don't try to do it all yourself at every step of the way. We will stop and validate and iterate. Do you have that prompt somewhere? I might. I might have kept it. I burned through an entire month's allotment of Claude 4 Max Mode tokens in about four hours. but got it done and the docks are now posted and it's like the first time the docs have built in 20 years
这是问题所在，这是挑战，制定一个我们如何逐步解决这个问题的计划。不要在每一步都试图自己完成所有事情。我们将停下来验证并迭代。你有那个提示词吗？我可能有。我可能保留了它。我在大约四个小时内用完了 Claude 4 Max 模式一个月的代币配额，但完成了任务，文档现在已经发布了，这是 20 年来文档第一次构建成功，
and they look much better and they're much simpler to maintain and you know we spotted a couple mistakes and a couple missing items in reviewing them but but those were easily fixed
它们看起来好多了，维护起来也简单多了，而且你知道，我们在审查时发现了一些错误和一些缺失的项目，但那些很容易修复，
and it got it all going and so you know it's like Could have I had done it faster by hand? Probably not. You know, maybe if you incorporate all the time into figuring out the prompt and all of that. But reading there was just so daunting that I wouldn't.
它让一切都运转起来了，所以你知道，就像我能手动更快地完成吗？可能不行。你知道，也许如果你把弄清楚提示词的所有时间都算进去的话。但阅读那些内容太令人望而生畏了，我不会去做的。
Yeah, but the time figuring out the prompt, even if you spend more time on it, that's higher value time than doing the repetitive task of going through these 7,000 functions. Exactly. And once I got it going, it was really nice. it would go through and it would say, like, oh, okay, so we're compiling the docs. We got this error from Doxygen. Here's my suggestion for how to fix it. And I would be like, like, that's great, do that.
是的，但弄清楚提示词的时间，即使你花更多时间，也比处理这 7000 个函数的重复任务更有价值。没错。一旦我让它运转起来，感觉真的很棒。它会遍历并说，哦，好的，我们正在编译文档。我们从 Doxygen 那里得到了这个错误。这是我关于如何修复它的建议。我会说，太棒了，就这么做。
And it would say, okay, there's 600 more identical issues. Do you want me to fix them all? And it would ask. And I'd be like, yes, fix them all. Done. Right? Right. And, you know, it would come up and say, you know, we got this other problem.
它会说，好的，还有 600 个类似的问题。你想让我把它们都修复吗？它会询问。我会说，是的，把它们都修复。搞定。对吧？对。而且，你知道，它会跳出来说，你知道，我们还有另一个问题。
Here's my suggestion for how to fix it. And I'd be like, no, I think there's a much simpler fix. Do it this way. It'd be like, okay, doing it that way. Just like, of course it always says like, that's a much simpler fix. Yes. Right, right. You're great.
这是我关于如何修复它的建议。我会说，不，我认为有一个更简单的修复方法。按这种方式做。它会说，好的，按那种方式做。就像，当然它总是说，那是一个更简单的修复方法。是的。对，对。你太棒了。
Yeah, so just got this iterative process going. And it was, you know, when we started, I don't know, it was something like 7,000 errors when we, you know, because it was like phase one. I'm like, just set up the framework so we can run do oxygen on all the sources. And don't try to fix any errors. Just get that going. It's like, well, if we got that going, it was like, okay, now there's 7,000-some-odd errors. So let's, my first thing was like, organize those into categories.
是的，所以就有了这个迭代过程。而且，你知道，当我们开始时，我不知道，大约有 7000 个错误，因为那是第一阶段。我心想，只要建立框架，这样我们就可以在所有源文件上运行 Doxygen。不要试图修复任何错误。只要让它运行起来。结果是，好吧，如果让它运行起来，大约有 7000 多个错误。所以我的第一件事是，把它们分类。
So we can try to attack these systematically. So it came back with like, here's my proposed categories. I'm like, okay, that looks great. Let's start with category number one, right? Let's figure out how to fix that. So it worked really well. So now I've got the ASL ducts are all back online for the first time in 20 years. So this is the, I mean, it's amazing story.
这样我们就可以尝试系统地解决这些问题。所以它回复说，这是我建议的分类。我心想，好的，看起来不错。让我们从第一类开始，对吧？让我们弄清楚如何修复它。所以它工作得非常好。所以现在我的 ASL 文档 20 年来第一次重新上线了。所以这是一个，我的意思是，这是一个了不起的故事。
And obviously, because as you mentioned, I think it's rocket fuel. So it's obviously I love to hear stories of other people thinking it's rocket fuel. But to play, not devil's advocate, but to answer the question that I'm sure, because we definitely have had, I've talked to folks, and people have mentioned in the get-up discussions that they find these tools counterproductive, et cetera, et cetera. And they're probably thinking, well, Sean said it's rocket fuel, but at the same time he said he lost a week debugging an issue
显然，因为正如你提到的，我认为它是火箭燃料。所以我显然很喜欢听到其他人认为它是火箭燃料的故事。但为了扮演，不是魔鬼代言人，而是回答我确信的问题，因为我们肯定遇到过，我和人们聊过，人们在 GitHub 讨论中提到他们发现这些工具适得其反，等等等等。他们可能在想，嗯，Sean 说它是火箭燃料，但同时他说他花了一周时间调试一个问题，
because it gaslit him. He also had to spend like a number of hours iterating on a prompt. Like that's not what I want to do. So how do you, I'm sure for the person that's thinking that in their head, how do you answer that like, oh, how can it be rocket fuel if you're ending up, you know, chasing bugs for days or a bug for days and you're having to do this iteration? Yeah. Curious to get your thoughts.
因为它对他进行了煤气灯操纵（gaslit）。他还不得不花几个小时迭代提示词。这不是我想要的。所以你，我确信对于脑子里有这种想法的人，你如何回答这个问题，比如，哦，如果你最终要花几天时间追查 Bug，或者不得不进行这种迭代，它怎么可能是火箭燃料呢？是的。很好奇你的想法。
If that person was in this conversation. Yeah. Yeah. You know, I think, you know, net, I am more productive. I also think I tackle things that I wouldn't normally tackle like this documentation problem, but there are other examples too, right, where it would just be like, you know, I could figure that out, but it's too much work and too low value. And so having even a device where you can have a conversation, it's like having a collaborator,
如果那个人在这次谈话中。是的。是的。你知道，我认为，总的来说，我更有效率了。我也认为我处理了一些我通常不会处理的事情，比如这个文档问题，但还有其他例子，对吧，它只会说，你知道，我可以弄清楚那个，但工作量太大，价值太低。所以即使有一个可以进行对话的设备，也就像有一个合作者，
right? Yeah. And that can have huge benefit. it. You know, and if you've ever worked with a collaborator or you've ever done anything that you don't know how to do, you go down dark alleys also, right? It's not like when I'm writing my own code. It's like, always perfect out of the shoot. It's like, I write, pile the code and throw it away. I'm like, well, that's not going anywhere. So I think the AI helps me do that faster, right? Right? So I don't view, you know, much of the time is wasted. And I learned pretty early on that if it's not, if I know what I want and it's not doing what I want, then just do it, right? Right. Right. Yeah. You know, early on, especially when you're trying to try out one of these systems, you're like, here's the problem and you're giving it a problem that you know the answer to and it gives you an answer that's close but not exactly there. And you're like, oh, well, what about this? And you're trying to
对吧？是的。而且这可以带来巨大的好处。你知道，如果你曾经和合作者一起工作，或者你曾经做过任何你不知道怎么做的事情，你也会走进死胡同，对吧？并不是说当我写自己的代码时，它总是从一开始就是完美的。就像，我写，编译代码然后扔掉它。我心想，好吧，那行不通。所以我认为人工智能帮助我更快地做到了这一点，对吧？对吧？所以我并不认为，很多时间被浪费了。而且我很早就学到，如果不是，如果我知道我想要什么，而它没有做我想要的，那就自己做，对吧？对。对。是的。你知道，早期，特别是当你试图尝试这些系统之一时，你会说，这是问题所在，你给它一个你知道答案的问题，它给你的答案很接近但并不完全正确。你会说，哦，好吧，那这个呢？你试图
convince it to get to the answer that you'd have in your head. And you just get frustrated and you bang your head against the wall, right? And it's like, that's not how you would work. with a person you know that's not how you should you should work with with one of these systems if you if you know the answer tell it exactly what you want and be very explicit um or just do it yourself i have found myself that like more and more like when i first started off i tried to have it to do everything and i got really frustrating and didn't but now it's like when i'm like okay like i can just do this i'll just go and do it yeah and there's you know now it comes up and it's like you know and if you've ever used
说服它得到你脑子里的答案。你只会感到沮丧，然后撞墙，对吧？这就像，这不是你与人合作的方式。你知道这不是你应该与这些系统之一合作的方式，如果你知道答案，就准确地告诉它你想要什么，并且非常明确，或者干脆自己做。我发现自己越来越多地，就像我刚开始时，我试图让它做所有事情，我感到非常沮丧，但现在，就像当我心想，好吧，我可以自己做这个，我就去做了。是的，而且你知道，现在它跳出来说，你知道，如果你曾经使用过
use clod it comes up for any changes it makes it gives you a diff right so you can accept or reject things individually and i will i don't know probably 70% of the diffs it presents i will edit them right yeah and and rather than modifying my prompt and being like like oh don't do it that way do it this way because it doesn't have any memory so unless i take the time to put it into a rule in most of the time it's not worth it it's not going to remember it so there's no use in me training it code faster than I can tell it how I wanted to edit it, right? One of the main reasons that I use GPD5 a lot alongside using like Claude and cursor is because GPT5 has, like it has this memory system that I opted into like six months ago.
Claude，它会对它所做的任何更改给出一个差异（diff），对吧？所以你可以单独接受或拒绝事情，我不知道，它呈现的差异中可能有 70% 我会编辑它们，对吧？是的，而不是修改我的提示词，说，哦，不要那样做，按这种方式做，因为它没有任何记忆，所以除非我花时间把它变成一条规则，否则大多数时候它不值得，它不会记住它，所以训练它并没有用，它写代码的速度比我告诉它如何编辑的速度快，对吧？我大量使用 GPT-5 以及 Claude 和 Cursor 的主要原因之一是因为 GPT-5 有，它有这个我六个月前选择加入的记忆系统。
And so now it knows like a lot of stuff. And so I know I can ask it a question with a lot less context. And it's like, oh, I know that this is Bryce. I know that he works at Nvidia and works. on Kuta. There is the occasional problem that my girlfriend and I share the chat GPT account, but I do legitimately think
所以现在它知道很多东西。所以我知道我可以用少得多的上下文问它一个问题。它会说，哦，我知道这是 Bryce。我知道他在 Nvidia 工作，在 CUDA 上工作。偶尔会出现我和我女朋友共用 ChatGPT 账号的问题，但我确实认为
that it had, like, I haven't checked its memory in great dent, but I do think that it's somewhere in the memory, it's got an understanding that there are two different people interacting here. But it's nice because, like, I know that if I go into chat GPT, that I can give it a lot less background. I'm not sure
它有，就像，我没有深入检查它的记忆，但我确实认为在记忆的某个地方，它理解这里有两个不同的人在互动。但这很好，因为，就像我知道如果我进入 ChatGPT，我可以给它少得多的背景信息。我不确定
whether Anthropic has a memory feature and whether it's something that cursor has turned on. I haven't seen it, but now I will look for it because if in the future, that would be great. And I frequently forget to kind of end one chat and start a new chat, and every once in a while look at the title of my tab, and it'll be like, I've been having five conversations in the same thing. And the bigger your context gets, I know it's summarizing it, but it's like, the crazier it's getting. The crazier it's getting. Yeah, and you're like, like, okay, stop. I had a I had like a four to five month period where cursor was nearly unusable for me because it like writes this database of like the current state of everything including the chat and it would just like it was every five to ten seconds the entire UI would lock up because for whatever reason they were doing some blocking IO and the UI thread which you should never do but they were doing but so I got very religious about like starting a new chat frequently because that seemed to make the. issue not so bad. Fortunately,
Anthropic 是否有记忆功能，以及这是否是 Cursor 开启的功能。我没看到，但现在我会去寻找它，因为如果未来有的话，那会很棒。我经常忘记结束一个聊天并开始一个新的聊天，偶尔看看标签页的标题，它会显示，我在同一个东西里进行了五次对话。而且你的上下文越大，我知道它在总结，但它就像，它变得越来越疯狂。越来越疯狂。是的，你会说，好吧，停。我有一段四到五个月的时间，Cursor 对我来说几乎无法使用，因为它写了一个包含所有当前状态的数据库，包括聊天记录，它只会，每五到十秒整个 UI 就会锁死，因为无论出于什么原因，它们在 UI 线程上做了一些阻塞 IO，这是永远不应该做的，但它们做了，所以我变得非常虔诚地经常开始新的聊天，因为这似乎让问题没那么严重。幸运的是，
latest version of cursor no longer have that problem. But yeah, for a long time, I was working with like every five to 30 seconds maybe cursor would freeze up. Just like, I could be like typing you. It would freeze up.
最新版本的 Cursor 不再有那个问题了。但是的，很长一段时间，我工作时，Cursor 可能每五到 30 秒就会冻结一次。就像，我可能正在打字。它就会冻结。
Just anything, it would freeze up. And I was like, why? Why? I found and reported a bugging cursor that was driving me nuts, which was if it was in the middle of doing something and you hit stop and then typed in a prompt right because you can see like like like you're doing the wrong thing so i would hit stop and then typed in in a prompt it would not even see the prompt and it would just pick up and continue yeah and uh that was driving
任何事情，它都会冻结。我心想，为什么？为什么？我在 Cursor 中发现并报告了一个让我抓狂的 Bug，那就是如果它正在做某事，你点击停止，然后输入一个提示词，因为你可以看到，就像你正在做错误的事情，所以我点击停止，然后输入一个提示词，它甚至看不到那个提示词，它只会接着继续，是的，而且，那让我
me insane it was like like stop stop stop stop right and the only solution was to just kill the tab And it's like, now I lost all my context. And so it was so painful. But I wonder if that's why it, like, they changed the interface in the last, I don't know, month or so. And now it's, uh, it'll give you a little thing. And it says run, skip or reject and tell you what it wants. Because there, there was a period of time where they stopped you from being able to stop it.
发疯，就像，停，停，停，停，对吧？唯一的解决办法就是关掉那个标签页。结果就是，现在我丢失了所有的上下文。所以这太痛苦了。但我不知道这是否就是为什么它，就像，他们在过去一个月左右改变了界面。现在，它会给你一个小东西。它说运行、跳过或拒绝，并告诉你它想要什么。因为那里，有一段时间他们阻止了你停止它。
And then I was like, uh, because I, I, I found that half the time it would work and half the time it wouldn't. You would give it. And then it would just go back. And I was like, did you not hear it? what I just said. But now they've got like a much better interface where they've got three different options.
然后我心想，呃，因为我发现有一半时间它会工作，有一半时间不会。你会给它。然后它就会回到原处。我心想，你没听到我刚才说的话吗？但现在他们有了一个好得多的界面，他们有三个不同的选项。
Typically you're hitting run. But it's only on tool commands. What they, what they need like if you're, if it's just making code changes, like if you can see that it's planning and making code changes that are in the wrong way, there's no like interrupt and tell like like, well,
通常你点击运行。但这只针对工具命令。他们需要的是，如果它只是在进行代码更改，就像如果你能看到它正在计划并以错误的方式进行代码更改，没有中断并告诉它，就像，好吧，
you can just interrupt it still. It's like skip or something or stop and then just type and it works. But usually I let it finish whatever it's doing and then tell it it's wrong. The other thing is if you don't, if you don't wait for it, if you just type, if you don't stop it, don't wait for it, you just type and hit return, it will cue it. And then
你仍然可以中断它。就像跳过或类似的东西，或者停止然后输入，它就起作用了。但通常我让它完成它正在做的任何事情，然后告诉它错了。另一件事是，如果你不，如果你不等待它，如果你只是输入，如果你不停止它，不等待它，你只是输入并回车，它会把它排入队列。然后
it will, at the next opportunity, we'll look at that cue and go like, oh, okay, I'm adjusting my plan. Yeah, I haven't had a chance to play around that much yet because I was like on a build of cursor from like six months ago to deal with the stability
它会在下一次机会时查看那个队列并说，哦，好的，我正在调整我的计划。是的，我还没有机会玩那么多，因为我使用的是六个月前的 Cursor 构建版本，以处理稳定性
issues. But have either of you two tried the like having multiple checkouts and like doing concurrent work like having multiple checkouts and multiple agents working at the same time Adobe's licensing doesn't allow us to run background agents which is kind of a pain however we're you know whatever we're paying to the cursor folks I find our token allotment too to be a bit limiting
问题。但你们两个有没有尝试过拥有多个检出（checkout）并进行并发工作，比如拥有多个检出和多个代理同时工作？Adobe 的许可不允许我们运行后台代理，这有点麻烦，然而我们，你知道，无论我们付给 Cursor 的人多少钱，我发现我们的代币配额也有点限制。
Connor kind of figured out how much Nvidia is paying and what are, I guess our limit's pretty generous because I've never run into it. Well, I also, I mean, we're not a lot to publicly talk. I asked if I was allowed to report, but they said you have to get permission. But because you can go to, I think this is for any organization.
Connor 算出了 Nvidia 支付了多少钱，我们的限制我想相当慷慨，因为我从来没遇到过。好吧，我也，我的意思是，我们不允许公开谈论。我问过是否允许报告，但他们说你必须获得许可。但因为你可以去，我认为这适用于任何组织。
It's not just for Nvidia because it's the cursor website. If you go to cursor.com slash settings and you have a corporate, whatever, and probably even if you have a personal one, they have a whole analysis tab where you can see over the last one day, seven days, 30 days, um how much you're using by language by requests and also to um it shows you your rank in your
不仅仅是 Nvidia，因为这是 Cursor 网站。如果你去 cursor.com/settings，你有企业版，无论什么，可能即使你有个人版，他们有一个完整的分析标签页，你可以看到过去一天、七天、30 天，按语言、按请求的使用量，以及它还显示了你在组织中的排名，
organization so you get to know what sean's rank is i'm that's a good question yeah i guess i guess sean can can go and look that up but uh the interesting thing is that i do almost all of my work on clod for sonnet which i don't think has any extra billing but if you are using the larger models like 4.1 opus or 4.0 opus. And I actually think cloud 4.0 opus, that one actually is more expensive than 4.1. And they recommend if you can to use 4.1. So if you're using a lot of the larger models, I think there are extra billing fees associated with that. But because I'm always using force on it, I basically accrue very little changes. I can see Sean's looking it up. Yeah, I'm just looking out of curiosity. I would love to
所以你可以知道 Sean 的排名是多少，我，这是一个好问题。是的，我想 Sean 可以去查一下，但有趣的是，我几乎所有的工作都在 Claude 3.5 Sonnet 上完成，我不认为这有任何额外费用，但如果你正在使用更大的模型，比如 4.1 Opus 或 4.0 Opus。而且我实际上认为 Claude 4.0 Opus，那个实际上比 4.1 更贵。他们建议如果可以的话使用 4.1。所以如果你正在使用大量更大的模型，我认为会有相关的额外账单费用。但因为我总是使用 Sonnet，我基本上产生的更改很少。我可以看到 Sean 正在查。是的，我只是出于好奇在看。我很乐意
support my ranking and how many folks at NVIDIA uses it, but maybe at a future date when they say we can talk about this, but we can not, unfortunately. I don't actually know that we can't. We might be able to. I just, I don't know where the green light was given, so or if it was given.
支持我的排名以及 Nvidia 有多少人在使用它，但也许在未来的某个日期，当他们说我们可以谈论这个时，但我们现在不能，很遗憾。我实际上不知道我们不能。我们也许可以。我只是，我不知道绿灯在哪里，或者是否给了绿灯。
Because when I look at mine, like, it, it says total lines accepted for the past, like, seven days is zero. Sometimes that's a bug. Sometimes it doesn't refresh for a while because I've looked at it a couple times and it says I haven't used it in like four days. and I'm like, what are you talking about?
因为当我查看我的时，它显示过去七天接受的总行数为零。有时那是一个 Bug。有时它不会刷新，因为我查看了几次，它显示我四天没用了。我心想，你在说什么？
I spent 10 hours a day. Like, I launch a go Chromecast to watch movies on our TV using Cursor now. I just open up Cursor and I say, hey, can you play, right now we're working through the Star Wars with, because my fiance, I haven't seen him. Wait, wait, wait, how do you, how does it know how to do that? So this is, it's beautiful. Folks don't understand. I'm living in the future here. We used to be sipping rocket fuel.
我每天花 10 个小时。就像，我现在使用 Cursor 启动一个 Chromecast 在我们的电视上看电影。我只是打开 Cursor，我说，嘿，你能播放吗，现在我们正在看《星球大战》，因为我的未婚妻，我还没看过。等等，等等，等等，它是怎么知道怎么做的？所以这是，它很美。人们不明白。我生活在未来。我们过去常常喝着火箭燃料。
Now I'm just living in the future. You can just ask it, please go play. return to the Jedi. If you have that movie sitting in a folder, it'll go find it. It knows probably like it's in the movies folder. It goes to movies. It does a grep for Jedi. Oh, there's a folder. Let me go check in there. Oh, there's an MKV. And then it goes, let me go search for a Chromecast. It does this dash-dash list, finds the Chromecast, sets up a connection, casts it. So I, like, we set it up. I just, I press one command. I have to hit enter, enter, because we don't have Yolo mode yet. But the point being is like, I want, like, I was talking to my
现在我只是生活在未来。你只需要问它，请播放《绝地归来》。如果你把那部电影放在一个文件夹里，它会去找到它。它可能知道它在电影文件夹里。它进入电影。它对 Jedi 进行 grep。哦，有一个文件夹。让我去那里看看。哦，有一个 MKV。然后它说，让我去搜索 Chromecast。它执行这个 --list，找到 Chromecast，建立连接，投屏。所以，就像，我们设置好了。我只需要按一个命令。我必须按回车，回车，因为我们还没有 Yolo 模式。但重点是，就像，我想要，就像我正在和我的
fiance, she moved, I need it in my sunglasses. I need it in my car. I need it everywhere. I need it in Chrome. Like it's still, I'm, so, okay, I don't want to shut on Google. However, I did just subscribe to Google, like, AI Pro to get Gemini Pro. The reason was I wanted Gemini in my spreadsheet because I had, like, the task was I had a list, like one column, which was names of people. And then in a separate spreadsheet tab, there were a much bigger list of the names of the people and their emails. And what I wanted was I was like, hey, here's like a list, like this tab has this list of 10 names of people. I want you to go and look up their emails in this other tab and fill them in here. And I thought this is going to be like the
未婚妻交谈，她搬走了，我需要它在我的太阳镜里。我需要它在我的车里。我需要它在任何地方。我需要它在 Chrome 里。就像它仍然，我，所以，好吧，我不想在 Google 上拉屎。然而，我确实刚刚订阅了 Google 的 AI Pro 以获得 Gemini Pro。原因是我想要在我的电子表格中使用 Gemini，因为我有一个任务，我有一个列表，一列是人的名字。然后在另一个电子表格标签页中，有一个更长的名字和电子邮件列表。我想要的是，我心想，嘿，这里有一个列表，这个标签页有这 10 个人的名字。我想要你去查看另一个标签页中的电子邮件并填在这里。我以为这会是
easiest thing. And I asked the Gem, the Gemini, they have the little Gemini thing integrated with sheets and I press the little button and it's like, oh, you got to pay money. So I'm like, all right, I'll go pay the money. So I get the subscription. And I go back in and I ask it. And it's like, oh, I'm sorry, our current tool support can't do this. We can't look at stuff in another tab. And so I'm like, all right, that's weird. And so I go and I copy the shorter list over to the other tap. So now all the data is in one tab.
最简单的事情。我问了 Gemini，他们有集成在 Sheets 中的小 Gemini，我按了那个小按钮，它说，哦，你得付钱。所以我心想，好吧，我去付钱。所以我订阅了。我回去问它。它说，哦，对不起，我们当前的工具支持做不到这一点。我们不能查看另一个标签页中的东西。所以我心想，好吧，这很奇怪。所以我去把较短的列表复制到另一个标签页。所以现在所有数据都在一个标签页里。
And I'm just like, I could pretty easily write a lookup function to do this at this point. And I ask it to do this again. And it's still like, I'm sorry, I can't help you do that. And so that I just take the whole spreadsheet. sheet, and I just upload it to chat GPT, and I ask chat GPT to do the same thing into output CSV, and it's done in like 30 seconds. So initial experience with Gemini's and with Google's integration, not great. But what I really want is I want a little chat thing in the browser
我心想，此时我可以很容易地写一个查找函数来做这个。我再次要求它做这个。它仍然说，对不起，我不能帮你做那个。所以我只是把整个电子表格，上传到 ChatGPT，我要求 ChatGPT 做同样的事情并输出 CSV，它在 30 秒内就完成了。所以对 Gemini 和 Google 集成的初步体验，不太好。但我真正想要的是浏览器里的一个小聊天框，
because there are so many mundane tasks that I have with manipulating web UIs, where it's like, oh, I need you to go and click on this button like a dozen times. Like, I was dealing with something with Tripit earlier today where, like, I needed to add 10 entries to trip it, and there's no bulk upload API. There's no public API. There was no way for me to automate it. Like, there's no way for me to tell an AI, like, just go do this. What I really wanted was a chat box in my browser and Google Chrome where I could just be like, you go do this for me, and I go off and do something else. I wonder if Copilot and Edge would do that for you.
因为我有很多处理 Web UI 的琐碎任务，比如，哦，我需要你去点击这个按钮十几次。就像，我今天早些时候在处理 Tripit 的事情，我需要添加 10 个条目到 Tripit，没有批量上传 API。没有公共 API。我没有办法自动化它。就像我没有办法告诉 AI，去帮我做这个。我真正想要的是 Google Chrome 里的一个聊天框，我可以对它说，你去帮我做这个，然后我去忙别的。我想知道 Copilot 和 Edge 是否能为你做那个。
I've never tried to have Edge control the webpage, but, I mean, it is integrated in their browser. Maybe we've finally found a reason for me to try using it. And I know that perplexity is working on a new browser, the company that I think, they said it wasn't a joke, but they offered to buy Chrome for $34.5 billion, which is a very brilliant marketing ploy, because apparently they're in court right now and may have to sell it. And like, if there's a buyer out there, they're not going to be able to say, no one would buy Chrome. Well, technically there's someone that offered to buy it. Why would no one buy Chrome? I don't know. It's too integrated with all Google stuff,
我从来没试过让 Edge 控制网页，但是，我的意思是，它集成在他们的浏览器里。也许我们终于找到了让我尝试使用它的理由。而且我知道 Perplexity 正在开发一个新的浏览器，那家公司，我想，他们说这不是开玩笑，但他们提出以 345 亿美元收购 Chrome，这是一个非常聪明的营销策略，因为显然他们现在正在法庭上，可能不得不卖掉它。而且，如果外面有买家，他们将无法说，没人会买 Chrome。好吧，技术上有人提出要买它。为什么没人会买 Chrome？我不知道。它与所有 Google 的东西集成得太深了，
and it would take like a decade to unwind it from their products. I don't know. Anyways, we haven't let Sean. Have you been able to find your settings? I did. I found my ranking. So I'm out of about a little over 8,000 engineers at Adobe. I'm ranked 1,200 for a number of accepted lines.
从他们的产品中拆解它需要十年时间。我不知道。总之，我们还没让 Sean 说。你找到你的设置了吗？我找到了。我找到了我的排名。所以在大约 8000 多名 Adobe 工程师中，我的接受行数排名第 1200。
That's pretty good. Yeah, but that's... I'm kind of surprised because I would, I would, you know, had you asked me, I would have said, oh, I'm probably, you know, near the top for, for users. But no, I'm, I am not. What do you think, Bryce? Are we allowed to, we can't say the numbers? Are we allowed to report the percentage?
那相当不错。是的，但那是……我有点惊讶，因为我会，如果你问我，我会说，哦，我可能在用户中名列前茅。但没有，我不是。你觉得呢， Bryce？我们被允许，我们不能说数字吗？我们被允许报告百分比吗？
Because I did calculate my percent. I think that's probably fine. I think you said probably said it. So, yeah, I'm, I'm just outside the top 10%. And I think a while ago, I was in, in the top 5%. I also don't super trust the up to date because like mine also shows that I have zero lines changed since August 6th according to these things and anyways I don't know how reliable they are but I also like you Sean was super surprised I was well of course I got to be the top 100 I'm a
因为我确实计算了我的百分比。我想那可能没问题。我想你可能说了。所以，是的，我刚好在 10% 之外。而且我想不久前，我在前 5%。我也不太相信它是最新的，因为我的也显示自 8 月 6 日以来我的更改行数为零，根据这些东西，总之我不知道它们有多可靠，但我像你一样， Sean，非常惊讶，我当然应该在前 100 名，我是
power user I'm a power user what are we talking about I'm in the top third but I think in my defense I I use chat GPT a lot for like directly for these things and I use other AI tools and also there was a four-month window where I could barely use cursor because of the freezes. Right, right. I think I use a wider variety of tools than you do, Connor. I think, like, I'm using, like, now I've been playing around with Gemini. I use perplexity. Like, I use a wider variety of things.
超级用户，我是超级用户，我们在说什么？我在前三分之一，但我认为为自己辩护，我经常直接使用 ChatGPT 做这些事情，我使用其他 AI 工具，而且有四个月的时间我几乎无法使用 Cursor，因为冻结问题。对，对。我认为我使用的工具种类比你多， Connor。我想，就像，我现在一直在玩 Gemini。我使用 Perplexity。就像，我使用的东西种类更多。
I use Gemini quite a bit now, actually. I used to go to ChatchipT, the free version, to answer questions. But ever since they updated the five. It blows my mind that you do not have the paid version of chat chbt My fiance does so if I need it I'll go use hers But ever since five I thought it's just gone down way like The nice thing about chat chepti 4 point whatever it was It was just fast now it's like oh I decided I need to think about your question
我现在确实经常使用 Gemini。我过去常去 ChatGPT 的免费版本回答问题。但自从他们更新到 5 之后。你没有 ChatGPT 的付费版本让我感到震惊。我的未婚妻有，所以如果我需要，我会用她的。但自从 5 之后，我觉得它下降了很多，就像 ChatGPT 4.0 无论它是什么，它很快，现在它就像，哦，我决定我需要思考你的问题，
It's like well I didn't ask you to I just want a rapid thing and Gemini I almost exclusively used it for 03 and 03 was pretty slow I did it for like I need some I need like a a little image generated and now I find that the Gemini ones way but anyways back to Sean so you're in the you're 1200 out of 8,000
就像，好吧，我没让你思考，我只是想要一个快速的东西。而 Gemini，我几乎专门用它做 03，而 03 很慢。我用它做，比如我需要生成一个小图像，现在我发现 Gemini 的方式，但总之回到 Sean，所以你在 8000 人中排 1200 名，
and and not as high I mean what do you think that means do you think that means that there's just a bunch of people doing like twice as much work as as you like you know it's just people are doing crazy things with this and they're running it overnight or something like that I don't know
而且没有那么高，我的意思是，你认为这意味着什么？你认为这意味着有一群人做的工作是你两倍吗？你知道，人们正在用这个做疯狂的事情，他们整晚都在运行它，或者类似的事情，我不知道。
interesting question but there'd have to be 1,200 people that are using it more than John. That's a lot of people yeah yeah yeah within the company and uh well the interesting thing is it's like number of lines accepted and i'm like do deleted lines count who is one of my questions there because i delete a lot of code oh yeah that's a good that's a good point uh sometimes it's like go eat this for me and it goes and deletes a bunch of stuff and like potentially you added 5,000 you know two weeks ago but then you deleted that same 5,000 does that like
有趣的问题，但必须有 1200 人比 John 使用得更多。那是很多人，是的，是的，在公司内部，而且，有趣的是，它是接受的行数，我心想，删除的行数算吗？这是我的问题之一，因为我删除了很多代码。哦，是的，那是一个好点，有时就像，去帮我吃掉这个，它就去删除了很多东西，而且可能你两周前添加了 5000 行，但后来你删除了那同样的 5000 行，那会
affect your net total. I would imagine that like it's the absolute, you know, like it's whether you deleted or added. It's changes, yeah. But yeah, it's a hard thing to measure. Yeah, because I had a previous boss who walked into my office one time and he said, he said, so I don't know how to read this. He said, I usually check the GitHub stats.
影响你的净总数吗？我想象它就像是绝对的，你知道，就像无论你是删除还是添加。它是更改，是的。但是的，这是一个很难衡量的事情。是的，因为我以前的一位老板有一次走进我的办公室，他说，他说，所以我不知道怎么读这个。他说，我通常检查 GitHub 统计数据。
And I always view you as one of my highest performers, but your total line count stats and GitHub are very negative. It's like, yes, I delete a lot of code. Which is a good thing. Which is a good thing. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com, for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions.
我一直把你视为我表现最好的人之一，但你在 GitHub 上的总行数统计非常负面。就像，是的，我删除了很多代码。这是一件好事。这是一件好事。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。那是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。